cette semaine rendent au pays vous
propose une randonnée parmi les
incontournables du cirque de mafate
la descente depuis le maïdo vers l'île
est des orangers
rendez vous sur la route forestière du
maïdo à la sortie de la forêt de
tamarins le départ du sentier qui amène
aux tic hall se situe devant ces
panneaux
une petite montée pour se mettre en
jambes tout en profitant des magnifiques
points de vue sur la côte ouest et on
atteint rapidement le petit col à 2020 9
mètres d'altitude
m
d'ici là vue est incroyable sur mafate
1000 mètres plus bas lila des orangers
et notre objectif un il est que l'on
peut aussi atteindre pas la canalisation
des orangers depuis sans souci
son prophète décembre par la
canalisation et pour le retour
redescendre par le maïdo c'est plus
rapide le maïdo et la canalisation c'est
plus facile
de l'année ce qu'on n'a pas à monter
toute la montée du maïdo justement
plongez dans le cirque par le mahi dos
et emprunter l'entrée la plus
vertigineuse de mafate à flanc de
remparts
pour atteindre la brèche 700 m de
dénivelé s'accumulent sur seulement 4
kilomètres ce sentier s'apparente donc à
un véritable mur comme celui qui m'ont
de grand ilet de la roche écrite ou de
hell bourg vers le cap anglais la
descente comme la montée sont donc
exigeante ne vous y aventurez pas à la
légère
au tiers de la descente un petit crochet
vers la crète permet d'atteindre un
point de vue sur l'autre partie du
cirque avec roches plates la nouvelle
jusqu'à marla et le teil bits
on comprend mieux pourquoi en dépit de
cette difficulté ce rempart est l une
des voies d'accès privilégiées des
chasseurs de noir marron qui dominait le
cirque avant de faire deux descentes sur
les campements
peu avant d'atteindre la brèche un
éboulis récent rappel que ce sentier
n'est pas exempt de tout danger c'est à
cause du cyclone qui viennent passer là
il ya eu beaucoup des bouillies beaucoup
d'arbres couchés après un cyclone moi
j'ai emprunté ce sentier là et ça a été
particulièrement difficile à cause de
l'eau dans un chemin des cascades qui
coulait il faut éviter de randonnées
pendant les périodes cyclonique après
ainsi comme et pendant les périodes de
pluie qui est annoncée une fois arrivé à
la brèche les grosses difficultés sont
derrière ce petit col taillé dans la
crête des orangers le point de
convergence de plusieurs sentiers celui
qui bascule de l'autre côté vers roches
plates ou celui que nous empruntons en
direction des oranges et
des marches d'escalier nous conduisent
le long de la rabine la brèche
influentes du bras grand-mère à l'aplomb
du piton berhane sur la crête des
oranges et les parois resserré semble
avoir été taillée à la hache
à la sortie de ce défilé les premières
cases de lille est des orangers vous
tendent les bras mais il faudra d'abord
remonté sur le plateau
une petite ascension d'une centaine de
mètres la seule du parcours et c'est la
fin de cette randonnée
j'ai toujours connu ce sentier depuis
que je suis tout petit des plages de 4
ans précisément j'ai fait pour la
première fois
je me passe très régulièrement pour
pouvoir accéder chez moi ou ils nous ont
mangés pourra résoudre une fois par
semaine depuis que j'ai 4 ans à fait fou
c'est des milliers de fois
on s'ennuie jamais parce qu'on remet à
bucky un caillou qui a bougé qui à
nouveau fleurs on remarque tout de suite
s'il ya quelque chose qui a changé du
fait mais qu'on connaît par coeur
justement
avant il y avait quasiment que les
mafatais qui passait par là les gens de
gauche plata les journées sont rangés et
là forcément il ya plus de toît du à
cause de l'accessibilité maintenant avec
le taxibus foyers en a toute l'année ils
viennent dans les îles est moi j'en
crois le très souvent quasiment tous les
jours
ce que je n'aime pas surtout sensible
c'est justement tout cette descente qui
capte les mollets qu'il faut vraiment
avoir un minimum
pouvoir faire ce sentier un minimum de
savoir pour mars et pour marcher